wow that was a seagull I'm pretty sure
what a beauty that I think has to be one
of the sounds that most reminds people
of Australia let's get started reaction
face
[Music]
mudpies vampire magpie is so good one of
my favorite but this is the only bird in
the world that does this sort of singing
where they sort of sound like a bit of a
demented synthesizer we Lulu this looks
like a cycling helmet it's like every
child in Australia and when you're
riding your bike to school and having to
ride like this
look at those wing beats what a majestic
creature
[Music]
did you just fall off the bike that's
what it looks like
everyone knows they swoop they're quite
dangerous I mean I don't know that they
necessarily kill anyone but they are
quite dangerous they have been known to
take out eyes Oh funny thing about them
is right is that they have particular
proclivities so some maggie's think that
bike riders are like devils and just go
for bike riders but only bike riders
that wear helmets some Magpies only
swoop posties that have got high views
on some Magpies only sweep specific
individuals because they can remember
faces so they know you only ones that
sweep males so manly ones and often they
don't swoop at all there's only a really
small percentage like 10% of males or
something that actually swooped and
they're only swooping when they've got
chicks in the nest in swooping season
every single bike rider has cable tires
all over their helmet sticking up like
hedgehogs I think people still get
swooped but what it does is means that
when the bird Clips you it's actually
higher than your head oh for god sake
levy is some people like used to put
eyes on their stack hat either on the
front or the back or both because that
idea of you looking at the magpie is
going to make them stop slipping
[Music]
think it worked what what has he done I
I think you can see how seriously
Australian taken that place weeping he's
got a fake Maggie there is super super
smart social animal they will know the
Magpies that live in their area both
within their territory and external
intimately so I don't know that they
would be fooled necessarily by that if
you're getting swooped there are a
couple of things you can try you can
take along an umbrella because
essentially it acts like a force field
if you had not to hurt the magpie just
to shield yourself the only real way
that you can avoid being swooped is by
not walking into the Magpies territory
and you can help other people by if you
know there's a sweeping magpie in the
area putting up a sign saying magpie
swooping report it to the magpie
swooping app there's different web sites
on the internet that collect this sort
of information so people can plan their
walking routes around the nasty Magpies
and remember that it's only a couple of
weeks it's not long just change your
route that was a siren
was that a siren they're one of the best
mimics in the world right there's
something like 35 sounds that they can
mimic including dog barks and humans and
all sorts of things
oh look how alert they are when they
heard did he did they went and looked up
the sound that you heard was a minor
call that's actually an alarm call this
is how smart that Magpies are right
they're listening to the sounds around
them and they basically translated for a
minor into magpie that there was a
danger not nothing go back to eating
Magpies are carnivorous the best thing
to feed them if you are going to feed
them is going to be things like
mealworms that actually have complete
exoskeletons they've got everything in
it that a magpie would normally be
eating when they're picking things out
of the ground do your research and make
sure that you're not home the birds that
you love so much clearly you love them
because we feed them all right so if
you've got a video that you've taken of
Australian nature out there and you want
us to have a look at it and see what we
can see why don't you subscribe and
leave us a link to the video in the
comments we'll make sure that we get to
it soon see ya